touchdown for vladimir putin in
uzbekistan the russian president here
for a meeting of the eight nation
shanghai cooperation organization ready
to do business with those world leaders
still ready to do business with him
the big one-on-one for him with china's
xi jinping a meeting which began with
president putin saying he understood
china's questions and concerns on
ukraine an admission that there were
some and precious little said from the
chinese side to prove him wrong
to be honest i don't think that china um
right now wants to be
really associated with russia and that
is why the first visit within the almost
three years of xi jinping outside of the
country was not russia was not moscow
but was central asia where
xi jinping
firstly comes as a
guest to the seo summit and not for
meeting vladimir putin
china and russia launched joint military
drills in the pacific this thursday with
russia reasserting support for the one
china policy
but china has stopped short of providing
military assistance to russia in its
fight with ukraine as well as avoiding
anything which might risk secondary
sanctions
what russia is doing in ukraine
contravenes a fundamental principle for
china which russia professed to abide by
before too which is the non-interference
in the domestic affairs and territorial
integrity of a sovereign state which is
why china objects so much to us support
for taiwan
and however much president putin asserts
the abiding friendship between these two
countries it is quite hard for china to
square that circle
but the no limits friendship the two
declared just before all this began
still counts for something
a vote at the international atomic
energy agency demanding that russia end
its occupation of the zaparisia nuclear
plant in southern ukraine passed with 26
votes in favor two against china and
russia defiant against the rest
dynamagne sky news moscow